hi I'm Dan Hynes and I am here with
Jonathan Pelham from 2k Australia how
are you I'm good how are you very well
thank you
we're here playing Borderlands the
pre-sequel we also have a few other
people playing with us we've got four
player co-op session happening first of
all is there action school showdown
showdown basically is a sort of a
gunslinger mode that lets you quickly
mow down groups of enemies it has to
kind of modes if your online sites and
it'll automatically snap your view to
the critical locations of enemies okay
or if you're just shooting from the hip
then it'll it'll move the reticle and
help you aim there's a little helm of a
vehicle there he is he's on the listing
ring all right so um what you can do is
you can just destruct a new stingray
from any existing stingray so you don't
have to trap all the way back to the 2d
vehicle so I'll just go up and say hey
give me a service Wow
you can spawn a vehicle off a vehicle
yeah that's cool
we did that because the stingrays a
one-man vehicles now yeah so you know
it's not as easy to you know we wanted
to it's kind of annoying when you know
you vehicles destroy and your friends in
a vehicle you don't have to go and walk
all the way back to the vehicle station
yeah so particularly we've don't know
you can only have one person on the
stingray won't make it really easy to be
able to get a new vehicle this reminds
me of that thing from Unreal Tournament
2004 where you could sort like pancake
people uh-huh yeah it's good it's it's
got a similar kind of evil yep so you
can't actually start the boost unless
you're on the ground yeah that's cool
he fries because of one of our abilities
yeah it looks like one of the one of the
others got a the cryo rocket version of
the Stingray gotcha
I was a couple of different weapons on
the scenery that you can get it's a very
cursorily like enemy thing that you got
yeah yeah it's definitely published by
there you go you've got kind of a
shotgun water as your second okay yeah
so it's sort of launching up and then
launching into multiple projectiles yeah
that's cool and also a bit hard and here
we go how large is this area that we
were in here it's pretty big sort of
like a hob yeah yeah this is um I guess
one of the larger areas you know no big
open terrain so yeah the mission that
we're doing right now is we're trying to
build the grinder which is one of the
new features that we've provided the
grinder will eventually let you once
it's assembled they'll let you dispose
of your old weapons by putting them in
yeah and we'll grind them up and it'll
spit out can you with them so it's kind
of like transmuting an item in Diablo or
or something like that
OOP sort of like a hyper Rodrick cube
and so does that change based on how
rare the item is and what its properties
are yep there are a whole bunch of
different recipes and you know it for
example you can do things like put three
common weapons in and a chance to spit
out a
an uncommon weapon okay yeah and then
depending on what kinds of weapons you
put in you can you know make it more
likely to get a particular type of
weapon out so you can start to learn the
recipe s'ti so why would you want to
sort of toss-up between doing that and
sort of selling the weapons back like at
what point are you going to be like
right I've got enough money to sort of
sort me out for now I'm going to start
gambling with this horik cube or the
grinder as you call it yeah it's um I
mean it's kind of obviously Oh God
yep awesome that's a friendly uh yeah I
mean it's really up to you like what
kind of value you put on money and how
much you think you need and you know
basically what it lets you do is have
another means of disposing of weapons
that you can you know they can lead to
something useful so for you know just
have to sell them or ditch them anymore
you can actually make use of them in a
way that essentially get a really
benefit
what are what levels of rarity for the
weapons do we have the pre-sequel
because I know like her the first one
eventually went up to like pearlescent
and and that kind of thing and we saw
like stopping at epic or legendary we're
stopping at legendary
okay yeah but otherwise it would be
intermediate priority system where these
guys are wearing oxygen masks as well
yeah so it's possible to shoot them off
with a headshot or is it yes yeah you
there we go
so basically it Chumlee stuns them them
and they start to lose help is higher
camp now we're hearing an oxygen bubble
here yep so now you're after you'll
immediately root be replenished and okay
you weren't afraid of it
Jack made a few little enhancements to
the claptrap so that he could be the
French oh he's just used one of his
action skills that there's a little mini
unique minion that sense of a truck yeah
that's cute deadly they're in spam
rockets in it that's good
what does that do well when there are
enemies around they'll fly around and
down and that green cloud around the
music rosy cloud okay yeah so he's
actually getting pretty powerful but
when there's no enemies around what else
is there to be the dance has fired off
Punk - it's a fact but that would have
been cool oh I think he's got some moves
oh yeah I'm busting out
okay so you've got two options you've
got you've got a straight-up grind ha ha
and then you've got your moonstone grind
and moonstones are our precious resource
it's similar to iridium in Borderlands
okay yeah so it's much harder to find
some enemies will drop it
you'll find it in chests and the keys so
the moon is not made of moon stone no
nor is it made of cheese oh it's a
supporting point it's rock but it does
have moonstone units and people like to
find that and and spend it on on Luke
okay so what what a moonstone grind does
you can spend some of that loot and two
things will happen it will increase the
chances that a better rarity than the
one you put in yeah spit out so you put
in blues you might get the purple out
now that can happen ordinarily but the
moonstone grind just makes it more
certain so this costs me moonstone to do
that that's correct okay a lot of
moonstone grind was what serine was
pulling off just then but oh well yeah
that's it's a good necklace so that's
still moonstone grind the other thing
that could happen is that there's a
chance that the weapon will be imbued
with special properties so it'll become
it'll get a moonshine okay so a
moonshine can apply to any weapon and it
basically just adds another little
ability to it okay so the loop off yeah
a little buff and it doesn't necessarily
affect the weapon it may affect your
character so excitable angle alright
let's do that yep
alright step down
Oh overloon shine if you look at it good
the weapon asked the little increases
when I damage my 5% yeah and if you
press and hold either stop your weapon
there you go so it's good all glow on it
look at that I like that yeah now if you
get insights you'll walk on to critical
locations oh wow yeah moving the mouse
you can retarget different enemies okay
I'll talk Fiesta that means free free
grenades for everyone I noticed a
grenade sort of flew out as I was on
claptrap when he's in copious mood he
can't stop throwing her but everyone
else just gets free grace I feel like
that is his normal mode but that is a
fake history yeah I only meant to say I
don't think that's coil phantom we had
to make some exceptions Oh something
else guys it's not normal
because the thing
Oh
it's rising a nice weapon so yeah
probably not are doing that it's
resisting here that's also in less with
this nice weapon looks like a sharp look
okay thank you very much for joining us
and showing us uh Borderlands the
pre-sequel my play when is it coming out
I was coming out October 14th in North
America and 16th in Australia New
Zealand awesome alright well for more on
Borderlands pre sequel check out
GameSpot calm